The Washington Post has a unique
solution to the Trump problem the left
goes after Peabody judge and the
president of Wesleyan defense woke
students I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show today's show is sponsored
by expressvpn it's how my listeners and
I secure their intranet join them and
expressvpn comm slash Ben okay so got a
lot to get to today here on the show
first I'm gonna fix my microphone
actually so well done producers okay
we're gonna get to all of it in just one
second let's begin with the Washington
Post finally deciding that something
very important has happened to change
the nature of the Trump presidency you
can tell the press are getting desperate
when they are now pushing the notion
that drag queens are going to end the
Trump press so they tried impeachment
ain't going anywhere
they tried the whole will have Hillary
Clinton beat him and that didn't go
anywhere
they tried the let's have a bevy of
candidates who aren't very good stand up
there and rip on Trump that ain't going
anywhere so now the Style section of the
Washington Post is very excited about
drag queens you see large men dressed up
in female garb in peculiarly sexual
sexualized ways that's what's going to
defeat Trump do you understand the
culture will defeat Trump a culture of
drag queens according to the Washington
Post there's a piece today in their
Style section it is titled how drag
queens have snatched the political
spotlight in the Trump era unfortunate
wording more Jude cos writing the murmur
spread through the crowd at the Lincoln
Theater but not because the headliner
Sasha velour the season nine winner of
RuPaul's Drag Race was about to take the
stage everyone was looking at the
balcony seats on the right where a
ponytailed woman in a navy pant suit was
taking her seat a OC someone yelled from
below the audience rose to give
representative Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
who has been outspoken about her
appreciation for drag on Twitter a
standing ovation two days later in
another Washington mashup of work and
work wer que a ha ha drag queen pissy
miles and won't one of the most charming
things about drag queen culture is the
is the choice of r-rated names clacked
down the halls of the Longworth building
in shiny red pumps Myles was there as a
journalist and commentator covering the
impeachment for live-streaming
crowdsource 2 News company haps
though she quickly became
storey herself it's not often that a
drag queen sachets her way through
official Washington at six feet eight
inches in heels and a wig serving looks
and political analysis in equal measure
the following week she was reporting
again this time from the spin room at
the democratic debate in Atlanta I I do
have a question about the use of
pronouns here if you're a drag queen
doesn't that by a necessity suggest that
you are a male if you're an actual
transgender person then you're not a
drag queen are you
you're just a transgender person so it's
weird to call a drag queen she when you
are he wearing makeup and heels and a
wig drag and politics says the
washington post have always been
intertwined
ever since the 1969 uprising at the
Stonewall Inn in New York where drag
queens and transgender women notably the
performer Marsha P Chance were among the
four mothers of the gay rights movement
and the lead-up to 2020 with drag
enjoying more mainstream popularity than
ever before drag queens are becoming a
perfect foil to President Trump you
might be losing when you're relying on
drag queens name pissy miles to oust the
President of the United States you're
the perp said the drag queen is the
perfect for us not like Adam chef not
Nancy Pelosi a drag queen who shows up
with a camera in pumps to a
congressional hearing pissy miles the
illustrious wise says in the queer
community and this is something that a
more broad audience might not know drag
queens are kind of looked at as
community leaders and mouthpieces they
ride out first with their sword in the
air and a lot of unfortunate language in
this piece the act of dressing in drag
has long been a political statement it's
an act of rebellion against societal
norms and an art form that elevates the
voices of disenfranchised communities oh
I just thought that it was guys dressing
a drag I thought that was like what it
was but apparently it is rebellion
against societal norms the most powerful
voices among us our people who Don the
garb of the opposite gender as drag has
attracted a new mainstream audience one
that might see it purely as
entertainment says the Washington Post
there have been efforts to make the
connection more overt House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi has appeared on drag race
and the show has hosted political
challenges for the contestants asking
them to participate in a mock
presidential debate and a trump themed
musical drag Con a convention for fans
of the Emmy winning show has hosted
panels on the art of resistance and drag
in trumps America in Los Angeles now
last April
maybe a girl again r-rated bizarre names
maybe a girl got it I get it it's Jesse
its pun it's fun you get it
defeating Trump with bunnery haha became
possibly the first drag queen to hold
public office when she was elected to
the Silver Lake Neighborhood Council
again I'm so confused
by the use of pronouns isn't it -
meaning to transgender people to take
non transgender people and call them by
the opposite gender how does this work I
guess this person is gender fluid so
when you actually have to use their
preferred pronouns not she Washington
Post how dare you the gender fluid
performer known for her satirical
impressions of Melania Trump Betsy DeVos
and Sarah Sanders announced her plans to
run for California's 28th congressional
district and the Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence a group of drag nuns which
isn't which isn't humiliating to
Catholics in any way it's not not
targeting a minor group in the United
States for mockery in any way have been
politically active since their founding
in 1979 no one commands attention quite
like a drag queen by the way if you pay
attention to drag queens on the street
however then this is because you're a
bigot even though obviously this is an
activity begging for attention it's a
matter of channeling that attention into
important causes says vellore the queer
community especially the drag community
is made up of many people who fall below
the poverty line and many black and
brown people said before I think the
popularity of drag in popularity of
those kinds of stories and narratives is
going to shift people's minds hopefully
that's right if you see an impoverished
person dressing in the garb of the
opposite gender and strutting around
town and you think to yourself that's a
strange life choice if you wish to rise
in the world at a Chase Manhattan Bank
then this is because your awareness has
not been raised pissy miles had no
reporting experience prior to her gig
with haps she was recruited by one of
the company's contributors who thought
she would be an eye-catching addition to
their coverage which targets younger
viewers she didn't realize she'd get so
much attention it's noticeable it's
notable that a drag queen was sent to
cover an event that wasn't overtly about
LGBTQ policy the one could argue that
impeachment is the ultimate case of I'm
sorry my dear but you are up for
elimination
oh you see me Oh Oh cuz it's like it's
like RuPaul Oh to our audience she's
another person an unusual person a
theatrical person said David Newman haps
his co-founder and chief content officer
he's talking to miles about covering
other news events throughout to 2020
audience members at that event mentioned
earlier were doubly starstruck by the
juxtaposition between velour and AOC and
even tried to form a selfie line to the
balcony until security shut it down
the congresswoman met velour backstage
filming a short video where they
fangirled over each other said velour
dressed in a pink gown velour thanked
her for facing the kind of online
bullying and rabid surreal hate from
some right-wing people Oh oh wow
drags ascension into the political
conversation says The Washington Post
has not been without challenges and wait
until you hear these challenges again
this is drag queens to stop Trump the
you get the sense the media might be
getting desperate over this whole Trump
thing I'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk about the
underwear that currently graced ER took
us are they as comfortable as they ought
to be if not then you are doing it wrong
you need to go check out Tommy John it's
the revolutionary underwear loungewear
and clothing brand that guarantees a
perfect fit and now they are stepping it
up this holiday season with an
unbelievable offer exclusively for my
listeners right now you can shop Tommy
John's biggest sale of the year and get
25% off site-wide if you'd have FOMO for
Tommy John well now is the chance to try
or give the most comfortable underwear
and loungewear on the planet to somebody
Tommy John wants everyone to experience
the amazing fit and feel I can testify
to it my wife wears Tommy John as well
she is crazy about Tommy John products
they've great products breathable
wedgie-proof underwear which would have
helped me a lot in high school and
ridiculously soft lounge were guaranteed
to fit perfectly plus you won't get that
wedgie as I say would have served me
well in my younger days give the gift of
comfort this holiday season with women
in addition gifts like loungewear and
underwear from Tommy John Plus save 25%
off site-wide when you go to Tommy John
calm and use the promo code Ben that's
code Ben at Tommy John calm the most
comfortable underwear and loungewear and
all the other stuff on the plan I mean
their stuff is really really first-rate
go check them out of Tommy John calm and
use code Ben to get to 25% off site-wide
alrighty so the Washington Post
continues with this extraordinarily long
piece about how drag queens are going to
save us all from from because by the way
President Trump has like nothing against
drag queens I mean he was the person who
was suggesting that Caitlyn Jenner who's
not a drag queen but that Caitlyn Jenner
could use any bathroom shoot that he
wanted because Caitlyn Jenner was a man
could use it any any bathroom he wanted
at Trump Towers the Trump doesn't care
about this stuff at all but apparently
drag queens are exactly the droids
you're looking for
according to the Washington Post
drags ascension into the political
conversation has not been without
challenges
drag queens story our a national program
that encourages queens to read to
children and libraries to spark protests
across the country well yes maybe
because if you have adults who are
trying to create gender confusion for
small children and parents who subject
their children to that that's a bad
thing maybe when you have adults many of
whom well some of them a minority of
whom shall we say have had checkered
histories we've had several cases of
drag queens story our readers having had
criminal records on on sexual matters
reading to children or showing up
dressed in skimpy outfits to read to
children yes that has created some
controversy as it turns out founders say
it teaches children empathy and
inclusiveness yes I'm sure
I'm sure that's what it's all about it
is not about the performative need for
many of the drag queens who want to read
to small children
Fox News anchor Martha McCallum rightly
told viewers the program aimed to
indoctrinate an unnecessarily expose
children to sexuality which of course is
exactly true a meme --nt widely shared
in 2017 featured a photo of a woman in
hijab sitting on a New York subway next
to drag performer Gilda Webb at which
Twitter user pole news network wonder I
Sibley caption this is the future
liberals want liberals responded that
they did in fact want that future and
mocked the sentiment by turning it into
a meme a similar thing happened to the
Lord after she posted her video with AOC
on Twitter conservative gay political
commentator dave rubin reposted the
video at the caption your democratic
2024 ticket ladies at gentlemen another
another twitter user with a handle BR
rect responded if she wins in 2024 that
pink tall person will be our Supreme
Court judge the Laura appropriated the
insult changing her name on Twitter to
pink tall person if these people are so
threatened by a little makeup and like
by theater talk about people who live
their lives defined by theater they
cannot think rationally if they're
afraid of this gorgeous lipstick and a
little corset tree well a lot of course
a tree nobody's afraid we're just
pointing out that this is a cultural
shift and that the media are cheering it
on all the way but if they really
believe that this is going to result in
frump losing the election they got
another thing coming I don't think most
Americans are interested in pissy miles
deciding foreign policy not because
pissy miles is unqualified to discuss
foreign policy on open minds
international relations background
but because if the left is forcing the
notion that gender is completely
malleable and that putting on a wig and
a dress is the essence of womanhood and
you get to use the opposite pronouns if
you do so I don't think most Americans
are on board with that it meanwhile the
radicalism of the left continues apace
pee poo de jedge under severe attack
today you knew this was coming right
that people who judge was gonna come
under severe attack now listen I've I've
said from the beginning that I thought
that people who judges most interesting
when he is moderate right that was his
original draw originally in this race I
said that Buddha judge was maybe the
most interesting Democrat in the race
specifically because he didn't seem like
an overt radical jerk IP Buddha judge
would spend his days talking about how
he would eat a chick-fil-a and he didn't
really see the controversy which was a
nice thing in our culturally polarized
country and then Buddha jej trying to
win over the left swivel to the left and
started talking about how you're a bad
Christian if you don't believe that his
same-sex marriage is just as non sinful
as your traditional marriage and
suggesting that you're a bad Christian
also if you don't believe in abortion on
demand which is a weird take well now
people who to judge his swiveled back to
the censor mainly because he's able to
contrast himself with Elizabeth Warren
who was wildly to the left and and
because of this he has been gaining in
the polls in Iowa and New Hampshire
where according to the Real Clear
Politics polling data
he's now ahead in Iowa and he is
basically running even in New Hampshire
under the polling average but in the
last couple of polls he's actually been
up in New Hampshire those are heavily
heavily white states very few black
Democrats live in Iowa and New Hampshire
very few black Americans live in Iowa
and New Hampshire my percentage and so
the grip on P blue de jedge has been
he's winning in all the white states but
as soon as you get down south he's gonna
get clocked because 60% of the
Democratic primary base in states like
South Carolina is black and people do
judge has right now a 0% rating among
black voters in places like South
Carolina
so the attacks were soon to come right
Buddha judge has been gaining steam and
Elizabeth Warren has been losing steam
and so you could see these attacks
coming from a mile away well the latest
attack which is trending on Twitter
today was by a guy named Michael Harriet
okay Michael Harriet is a writer for the
route and he wrote a very long piece
talking about how about--how Peabody jej
is a terrible person the title of the
piece is Pete Buddha jej is a lying MF
he's not just he's not just a person
with very little black support he has a
lying MF so what makes people to judge a
lying MF as it turns out people judge
has suggested in the past that
educational disparities between racial
groups groups may not be entirely due to
systemic discrimination I know
super duper controversial then not every
disparity is due to discrimination or
systemic racism now in today's modern
Democratic Party this is the stuff
you're not allowed to say P Budaj has
said this back in 2011 but it doesn't
matter it's being brought up again Anu
he said a reasonable thing and now
people on the Left are losing their
bleep over it okay so this piece was
trending on Twitter today by Michael
Harriet and here is is what the piece
says seven hundred three thousand
thousand three hundred twenty two
dollars I hid it in a white Piggly
Wiggly bag in the back of the dishwasher
every single time I return to a tiny
apartment I opened up that Navajo white
Kenmore dishwasher and made sure it was
there it was not a gift it was not a
reward it wasn't even mine and it still
wasn't enough
I am from what most people would call
the hood the bad section of town you
know where black people live says
Michael Harriet during the crack
revolution of the late 80s to get to
school every day I would frequent I
would give a friendly nod as I walked
past the early rising dopeboyz I'm he
entered through the projects and if it
had recently rained I waited for someone
to help me put a ten-foot long wooden
plank across a ditch that separated the
black part of town from the bucolic
neighborhood where the only High School
in town was located if no one was there
or for prankster and hid in the
makeshift bridge then I had either leap
across or walked the long way around
adding an extra 15 minutes to my morning
walk our neighborhood had no busses so
either you walk that balance beam
between the projects for the 30 minute
stroll or you said f it
I never said eff it but if I did it
wouldn't have been because of my lack of
role models if I chosen to keep my
mama's lights on instead of making it
that daily Trek my decision wouldn't
have been based on a trap illogical
dearth of motivation or communal
ambivalence as I grow older I realized
that I was not gifted talented or even
diligence I'm just a lucky mf'er
presidential candidate Peabody judges a
lucky MF or two by the way in this whole
piece Michael Harriet never explains
what separated him from the quote
unquote dope
boys why he went to school and they
didn't for example what does that have
to do with luck it's a public school
they too could walk across that plank
but according to Michael Harriet it was
just a matter of luck if he walked
across that plank to a public school but
presidential candidate Pete Buddha judge
is a lucky MF or two by the way
living in America you're lucky I'm
effort some people are luckier than
others I grew up in a two-parent
household which is the greatest
privilege you can have in the United
States right is the greatest starting
point you can have in the United States
it's to rub in a solid two-parent family
this is why there's a serious problem in
communities that have a rising single
motherhood rate right 71% of black kids
in the United States are born into a
single-parent household that creates
additional stressors less time for moms
to do homework with the kids it creates
a need sometimes for kids to get out on
the street and earn it's a real problem
it's a real problem hey that's an actual
privilege right because that's something
you're born with
now does that mean you should be
punished for that no it means we should
encourage more people to get married
before they have kids obviously but
we'll get to Michael Harriet's actual
critique of people who judge in just one
second and it does demonstrate where the
heart and soul of the Democratic Party
are now and how you are not allowed to
say basic truths because people judge
made a boo-boo
you see he said a basic truth back in
2011 and this is not acceptable it's not
acceptable get to that in just one
second first let's talk about how to
make your home better okay what so you
already replaced all of the paint you
already did the floors you got yourself
some new furniture but something still
looks a little bit dingy you know what
it is it's the blinds I know you haven't
looked at the window coverings in years
because hey they covered the windows
they did what they were supposed to
there's only one problem they look
terrible you need to replace them right
now head on over to blinds comm going
blind shopping isn't one of the things
that I wake up thrilling to in the
morning but blinds calm knows that and
that's why they make it super easy you
just send them pictures of your house
and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms and here's
the best part
if you accidentally miss measure or you
pick the wrong color if you make a
mistake
blinds comm will remake your blinds for
free they've really made it easy for you
so there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make your place look
like a set from the wire and for a
limited time it get 20% off everything
at blinds calm when you use promo code
Ben that is blinds.com promo code Ben
for 20% off everything faux wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades and more
blinds calm promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do up
I that's a pretty great deal blinds.com
promo code Ben for 20% off everything
okay so Michael Harriet says that
presidential candidate Pete Buddha judge
is a lucky MF or two he attended one of
the best private schools in the country
that was quite literally on the campus
of one of the best colleges in the
country University of Notre Dame where
his father worked as a professor for 29
years his mother taught in an even
better more elite school and if you
asked how he got into Harvard who became
a Rhodes Scholar mayor Pete would
probably insist it had nothing to do
with whiteness he would likely tell you
he valued education and had great
montreux ma role models
both of which are probably true there is
no question that he is intelligent
hardworking and well educated but he
didn't have to jump a ditch so when a
clip surfaced of Buddha judge explaining
why Negro kids fail at school so often
his answer made perfect sense okay
here's people to judge his answer that
drove Michael Harriet to call people to
judge her lying mf'er and caused that
phrase to trend on Twitter its need to
see evidence that education is going to
work for them right so you see a lot of
parts that's part of the motivation yeah
because you're motivated because you you
believe that at the end of your
educational process there is a reward
there's a stable life there's a job and
there are a lot of kids especially the
lower income minority neighborhoods who
literally just haven't seen it work
there isn't somebody they know
personally and I think testifies to this
value of education so yeah okay and for
this he is he's termed by Michael
Harriet a lying mf'er why well says
Michael Harriet this is not a
misunderstanding this is not a
misstatement people judge went to the
best educational institutions America
has to offer and he more than anyone on
the on the GD planet knows that
everything he just say is a bald-faced
lie well no actually nothing he said was
a bald-faced lie nothing he explicitly
talked about lack of opportunity on the
other end for a lot of young black
people and apparently this is racist
it's also racist if you suggest that
there is a problem in a lot of
inner-city communities by the way to
exist in white Appalachia as well as JD
vans has talked about in hillbilly ology
where education is not provided is not
invested with the same value as other
values on the hierarchy but apparently
according to Michael Harriet if you
point this out if you point out that not
every discrepancy is discrimination not
every disparity between groups is
discrimination this makes you a lying
mf'er so according to Michael hare
what causes the entire racial gap in
education he says majority minority
schools received 23 billion dollars less
in funding the majority white schools
according to a recent survey by IDI
build okay well by the way that is
largely due to lower property tax
expenditures in largely minority areas
because of endemic poverty meaning that
if you have a poverty ridden area many
local public schools are powered by the
property taxes in those areas if you're
not going on during a lot of property
tax there's not as much money to spend
said black students in Indiana the state
where Budaj serves as mayor and across
the country are disciplined more harshly
than white students but even though
buddha judge has never attended a school
with more than 10% black students he
thinks he knows what's stopping black
kids from achieving their educational
dreams apparently it's not the fact that
the unemployment rate for black college
grads is twice as high as the
unemployment rate for white grads black
college grads are paid 80 cents for
every dollar a white person with the
same education earns white people leave
college with lower debt and higher
earnings white kids get more resources
more advanced classes and have access to
more technology but Pete says it could
all be solved with a vision board
mayor Pete's bull bleep er II is not
just wrong it is proof it proves as
Micheal Harriet that men like him are
more willing to perpetuate the fantastic
narrative of Negro neighborhoods needing
more role models and briefcase carriers
than make the people in power stare into
the Sun and see the blinding light of
racism Kenalog moderates would rather
make bleep up out of whole cloth than
wade into the waters of reality
pee poo de jedge doesn't want to change
anything he just wants to be something
this is not just a lie of omission says
Michael Harriet it's a dangerous
precedent this is why institutional
inequality persists not because of white
hoods and racial slurs it is because
this insidious double-talk erases the
problem by camouflaging it because it is
painted as a problem of black lethargy
and not white apathy Pete Buddha judges
standing over a dying man holding the
oxygen machine in his hand and telling
everyone now he doesn't need CPR he's
just holding his breath negligent
homicide is still homicide and then this
guy concludes his piece by talking about
where he got all this money apparently
he got the money from the quote unquote
dope boys he walked past everyday who
collected all of the ones and a few $5
bills from guys on the black and handed
to him when he left college he still
doesn't explain why exactly he kept
jumping the ditch but a bunch of the
kids in his neighborhood did not jump
the ditch and he doesn't explain that in
any way now does this mean that everyone
faces the same obstacles in life of
course not you'd be a fool to suggest
that everyone
faces the same obstacles in life but you
would also be a fool to suggest that the
discrepancies in educational performance
between black students and white
students are entirely due to
institutional discrimination it's just
not true and in a second I'm going to
show you that it is just not true
with a few quick facts and figures many
of them garnered from the census data
okay we'll give you that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
need to avoid credit card debt okay I
was always taught that you pay your
credit card off on time right if you're
gonna take a credit card at all then you
got to pay it off on time because if you
don't those interest rates start to
skyrocket on you but if you weren't
taught that or if you just were amiss
for a month suddenly can find yourself
behind the 8-ball and people are
constantly telling you you should take
out a new credit card there all sorts of
credit card offers over at the local
mall why don't you just do it well you
shouldn't but if you did and now you're
in debt you need Lending Club Lending
Club helps you consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself and how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued again
it's easy to get into debt you just made
a mistake but now you need to get a fix
to be a responsible adult go to Lending
Club comm / pin and check your rate in
minutes borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / been again
Lending Club com / been all loans made
by web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender so when I talk about the
radicalism of the Democratic Party when
I think what the radicalism of many
members of the media
yeah beyond the whole drag queens are
gonna take down Trump you have this
whole article about how people judge is
not just wrong
a lying mf'er for suggesting that kids
from lower-income neighborhoods haven't
seen education work because there isn't
someone they know personally who
testifies to the value of education that
happens to be true that happens to be
true
on a statistical level for example there
is a study that was recently done by
researchers at Stanford Harvard and the
Census Bureau it was about income
inequality and income mobility in the
United States what the study noted and
this is fascinating is that black women
when you adjust for income
gap in the households where they grow up
black and white women raised in similar
households do not have an income gap the
income gap does not exist in fact
according to the study black women earn
slightly more than white women
conditional on parents income there is
little or no gap in wage rates or hours
of work between black and white women
black women have higher college
attendance rates than white men
conditional on parental income so what
happened to the racism of its
institutional racism than what you would
expect is that black women despite
adjusting for all other factors would go
to college at a lower rate they would
earn less but that is not true that is
not true the same study by the way found
that income gap between whites and
Hispanics were converging and also
asian-americans actually earned more
than whites raised the same income level
presumably that isn't discrimination in
favor of Asian Americans the study also
discusses one of the reasons why black
men who are raised in fairly
economically privileged households
actually fall into poverty a lot more
often according to the study black men
raised in the top 1% by millionaires or
as likely to be incarcerated as white
men raised in households earning about
$36,000 is that the fault of white
racism the study itself finds that the
relationship between racism in a given
area and incarceration rates is not
statistically significant also also if
affirmative action programs in colleges
and high schools are defined by race
rather than on income high income young
black men may still end up paying a
price in the workplace on the other ends
when you talk about unemployment rate
among black college graduates one of the
problems is that affirmative action
programs creates a negative stigma
around black graduates that stigma may
be unfair but it does exist in the
workplace hey also if you're going to
look at underperformance in the
educational sense this study from
Harvard and Stanford and Yale again
what it shows is that social fabric
matters a lot
meaning that it's not just about having
a bad in the home it's about how many
fathers there are in the neighborhood so
even kids who grew up in a single mother
home if they grew up in a neighborhood
where there are lots of fathers around
to provide parental figures then they
define black heads but if they're
growing up in an area where there are no
fathers around and they don't do fine
hey this is this is really you know this
does demonstrate this does demonstrate
this study that disparity does not
always equal discrimination and in fact
in the 1980s black anthropologist John
OGG who theorized that black kids were
often penalized socially for acting
white meaning engaging in education in
2004 Barack Obama said quote children
can't achieve unless we raise their
expectations and turn off the TV sets
and eradicate the slander that says that
a black youth with the book is acting
white ten years later in 2014 he says
there's an element of truth in the
accusation that too many black parents
denigrate education we're okay if boys
are reading too much then well why are
you doing this or why are you speaking
so properly black kids spent
significantly less time on homework than
any other race of children Asian kids
spend significantly more time on
homework Harvard's Roman friar a black
professor formalized a quote particular
peer effect acting white which
potentially contributes the ongoing
puzzle of black underachievement
statistically speaking high school
graduation rates are massively different
between the races okay that is not an
effect of quote unquote systemic racism
that is people who are not going to
school okay that is other factors that
are driving kids not to go to school
other than racism presumably again these
are majority minority schools in many
cases black kids across the country have
a significantly higher dropout rate
graduation rates nationally black
students graduated a rate of 69 percent
as of 2011-2012
Hispanics graduated at 73 percent
White's graduated at a rate of 86% by
the way Asian Pacific Islanders nearly
always graduate state-by-state
at a higher rate than white kids hey or
how about the the idea that was pushed
forward in this Michael Harriet piece
that the big problem here is that in
schools black kids are punished
differently than white kids well again
that ignores the question as to whether
black kids not on an individual level
but on a group data level are on average
acting out more than white kids in
school
the Justice and Education Department's
released an annual report called
indicators of school crime and safety as
of 2018 black students have
self-reported this according to Heather
McDonald over at City Journal being in a
physical fight at school at over twice
the rate of white students in 2015 a
data point certainly relevant to the
question of racial rates at school
discipline schools that were 50 percent
minority or more reported weekly gang
activity at nearly ten times the rate of
schools where minorities constituted
five to ten percent wente percent of the
population reports of gang violence in
schools with less than five percent
minority population or too low to be
usable statistically weekly widespread
weekly disorder in classrooms was
reported in schools with at least 50%
minority populations at more than five
times the rate as in schools with five
to twenty percent minorities these facts
are rather relevant to judging the
likelihood of student misbehavior and
resulting discipline so again this
article that Michael Harriet pushes is
based in simple belief that all
disparity equals discrimination and the
fact that Buddha judge didn't just bow
to that in 2011 means that Buddha judge
doesn't take black concerns seriously
but if you take black concern seriously
then you should actually look to some of
these systemic underlying factors that
cannot be blamed on quote unquote
institutional racism we're just throwing
money at the problem by the way the same
people who are blaming institutional
racism and systemic discrimination are
the same people who are opposing school
vouchers which would allow a lot of
these kids to escape bad public schools
and go to better public schools many of
these same people are anti development
and gentrification which would allow the
tax base to rise in these areas and
allow for more spending on local public
schools when it comes to post-secondary
graduation rates there's a major
disparity between black and white in
post-secondary graduation rates talking
about college students the six-year
graduation rate is according to the
National Center for Education Statistics
the six-year graduation rate for
first-time full-time undergraduate
students who began their pursuit of a
bachelor's degree at a four-year degree
granting institution in fall 2010 okay
again this is six-year graduation rate
at a four-year university is
seventy-four percent for Asian students
sixty-four percent for white students
and forty percent for black students is
that due to institutional discrimination
according to the UC NF Torg a recent UC
NF found that african-american students
were more likely to take remedial
college courses than any other student
group sixty-one percent of black
students who took the AC T in 2015
meant none of the four AC T college
readiness benchmarks nearly twice the 31
percent rate for all students so again
the relatively low retention rate
of black students across the nation
continues apace among students enrolled
in four-year public institutions as of
46 percent of black students completed
their degree in six years black men were
down at 40% so again this is to blame
all of this on institutional
discrimination then suggest that people
to judge is a racist because he's
pointing out it's not all due to
institutional discrimination
demonstrates how far left the Democratic
Party has moved he even points this
thing out makes you unwell in the in the
Democratic Party okay we'll get to more
of the Democratic radicalism in the
agenda being embraced in just one second
first let's talk about the earbuds that
you are using to listen to the show so
maybe you're using the old-fashioned
earphones Lund fit over your whole ear
you take them off your ears are sore
maybe you have the earphones that are
connected to the wires you take them off
you put them in your pocket and then
later you have to untangle that whole
shebang no I have a better idea how
about you get some earbuds that are
wireless and don't cost you a fortune
there's no need to go crazy this year
I'm letting you know ahead of time about
an amazing Black Friday Cyber Monday
deal on something you're gonna use every
single day a pair of wireless earbuds or
headphones from Ray Khan you guys know
about Ray Khan awesome company founded
by Ray J he was sick of premium audio
being so expensive so he and a bunch of
audio engineers and music industry folks
throw up the rate cons line of awesome
wireless headphones and earbuds they
sound just as good as other premium
brands but they started about half the
price you're saving a lot of money you
don't have the stems or the wires to get
in your way it is true that what it's
true wireless audio with seamless
bluetooth pairing go to by Raycom slash
Ben right now to check out ray cons
Black Friday and Cyber Monday savings
they're already featuring them I can't
tell you how good the deals will be
they're awesome that's by Ray can calm
slash pens to get an amazing Black
Friday deal on ray cons now is the time
to buy for going to buy ray con calm
slash pen go check them out right now
okay we're going to get back to the
extremism of the Democratic left in just
one second and why this is leading
President Trump
toward a reelection victory when you get
to that in just one second first if
you're not already a subscriber you
really are missing out head on over to
daily wire calm slash subscribe for as
little as 10 bucks a month you get our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
wire app pretty awesome feature if you
haven't checked it out yet and with
Thanksgiving break approaching we're
saying a few days off the show but that
does not mean
we won't be bringing you the
hard-hitting news that you crave in fact
we have some pretty awesome news for
Black Friday so be sure to stop by for
some awesome deals right now by the way
if you choose that new All Access plan
you get all of the great things that
come along plus the legendary leftist
Cheers tumblr our brand new ask me
anything style discussion feature I
believe I'm doing one of those today
stop the prising depriving yourself come
enjoin the fun over at daily wire comm
where the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so as I say the Democratic
Party is moving in this radical
direction there's a reason that there's
hit piece on boo to judge wait how far
left are the Democrats I'm now defending
people to judge that's how far left the
Democrats have gone because if you are
even remotely reasonable watching
Peabody judge be slammed as a lying
mf'er for simply suggesting that not all
educational disparity is due to
institutional discrimination that that
should be rather off-putting to you
since what Buddha judge was saying there
happens to be upset well apologize by
the way within 24 hours right there's no
way he withstands the scrutiny on this
one
meanwhile the Democrats are moving past
safe legal and rare according to the New
York Times the Democratic presidential
candidates don't want to simply defend
abortion rights they want to go on
offense because nothing says going on
offense like killing babies the
Democratic presidential field according
to Maggie asked her reporting for the
New York Times has coalesced around an
abortion rights agenda more far-reaching
than anything past nominees have
proposed according to a New York Times
survey of the campaigns the positions
reflect a hugely consequential shift on
one of the country's most politically
divisive issues every single candidate
the time surveyed supports codifying roe
v-- wade in federal law allowing
Medicaid coverage of abortion by
repealing the Hyde Amendment so your
taxpayer dollars would pay for somebody
else's abortion it used to be the
position of Democrats including Joe
Biden who repeatedly vote for it voted
for it that taxpayer dollars federal
taxpayer dollars should not be spent on
the killing of the unborn now every
single Democrat wants to change the law
so that your taxpayer dollars can be
spent on the killing of unborn babies
and every candidate wants to remove
funding restrictions for organizations
that provide abortion referrals in other
words they want to restore all of the
funding all of the title 10 funding for
Planned Parenthood almost all of them
say they would nominate only judges who
support abortion rights it I do find it
amusing by the way that if Republicans
were to say we will only support a judge
who believes that the Constitution does
not protect abortion everybody how dare
they with their litmus tests judges
shouldn't have litmus tests Democrats
are out there meanwhile being like if
that judge right there if I don't know
that he's going to be okay with us
plunging a scissors into the skull of a
nine month old baby well then you know
I'm going to that judge cannot sit don't
worry don't let this test all I'm saying
is skull scissors baby head that's all
I'm saying
oh I'm staying there
few support restrictions on abortion
late in pregnancy seven say abortion
pills should be available
over-the-counter 9 want a federal
approval process for state abortion laws
so they want the federal government's
have to sign off on state abortion laws
which violates principles of federalism
Joe Biden is seeking to recast himself
as a full-throated champion of abortion
rights
jacqueline ayers vp for government
relations in public policy a Planned
Parenthood says what you've seen is that
it's no longer okay for any candidate
just to say they're pro-choice they're
being very specific on how our rights
are under attack
how access to abortion is being
undermined in this country and putting
forth plans to protect and expand rights
now there's only one problem with all of
this which is that the vast majority of
Americans want some restrictions on
abortion very few Americans are for
abortion on demands on points of birth
and it is obvious that the Democrats
have abandoned the old language the safe
legal and rare language really which at
least made Democrats appear ambivalent
about the moral qualms surrounding the
killing of the unborn instead they're
like celebrate cheerier abortion
according to the New York Times the most
striking change beyond individual
policies is how unapologetic candidates
tone on abortion rights has become
advocates have traditionally said they
support the right to choose abortion not
the abortion itself and Democrats have
said it should be safe legal and rare
public debate has commonly centered on
procedures after 20 weeks gestation
which account for less than 1.5 percent
of abortions the discussion has often
been on opponents terms now every
candidate says the next president should
actively reframe the debate their
language focuses on health care bodily
autonomy and even at times the idea of
abortion as a positive force enabling
women to control their lives and
increase their economic security
Elizabeth Warren said in the last debate
that abortion is healthcare and health
care is a human right and she argued
that abortion rights were also economic
rights pretty much everybody else
avoided the language rare I said it
should be safe and legal but not rare
asked if they supported restrictions
after 24 weeks which is a six-month-old
baby which is when a healthy fetus can
survive outside the womb generally every
single Democrat said no every single
Democrat except for Joe Sestak who
doesn't count said no it's absolute
absurdity but this is your new
Democratic Party drag queens to defeat
Trump people to judge is evil for
suggesting
educational disparities are not entirely
due to institutional discrimination and
also abortion should be safe and legal
all the way to points of birth this is
your Democratic Party and the candidates
are just awful they're just terrible and
Bernie Sanders is out there basically
acknowledging he's gonna raise taxes on
everybody making more than 29 grand in
the United States at least the dudes
honest points for honesty to Bernie
Sanders who points out that his plans
required taxes to be raised on everybody
fairly dramatically what we will do is
have a four percent tax on income
accepting the first twenty nine thousand
dollars all right okay so that that is
that is not a great pitch but go for it
man
meanwhile you got Elizabeth Warren out
there lying about her stories so
Elizabeth Warren has turned out to be
deeply inauthentic
she's still telling this lie that she
was fired for being visibly pregnant
back in the 1970s despite the fact that
there's contemporaneous documentation
showing that she was unanimously offered
a RIA on her teaching contract and she
had said previously the reason that she
didn't continue is cuz she didn't feel
like doing it she's still telling this
ridiculous story that she was fired for
being visibly pregnant this is similar
to her ridiculous story that she was the
first breastfeeding mother ever to take
the New Jersey bar exam which of course
is false
here is Elizabeth Warren saying things
that aren't true by the end of the first
year I was visibly pregnant and the
principal did what principals did in
those days wished me luck and hired
someone else for the job okay well this
is just one of the one of the fibs that
she has been telling my best available
evidence meanwhile there's another fib
she's been telling nakorn Chrissie
Clarke at the Federalist senator
Elizabeth Warren of Massachusetts told
the school choice activist last week she
sent her kids to public schools the new
records showed that her son Alex Horne
attended private schools in both of
Austin Texas and Haverford Pennsylvania
the New York Post reported that Warren
initially sent her son to a private
school in Austin while she was a
professor at University of Texas Austin
but Warren also sent her son to have
referred school in Pennsylvania while
she was teaching a University of Penn
Alex Warren was born in 1976 so he was
15 years old when he started at
Haverford and 17 years old by the time
by the end of his time there also a
yearbook photo was submitted
the Federalists the same Haverford
alumnus said tuition at the time of Alex
Warren's graduation was approximately
$11,000 a year Warren told the school
choice activist that she that her kids
went public schools right a school
choice activist named Sarah carpenter
said I read that your children went to
private schools and Warren said no my
children wants public schools because
Warren is a liar this is what she does
but this is your modern Democratic Party
unfortunately it would be better to have
a couple of reasonable parties but
unfortunately we don't and the leading
bleeding bleeding edge of the Democratic
Party still exists on college campuses
with idiots like Michael Roth who is the
Dean of obrah of Wesleyan University as
a piece at cnn.com today titled what the
woke student and the welfare queen have
in common
they're both myths don't you see the
president of Westland he says every age
seems to need a bogeyman some negative
image against which good people measure
themselves when I entered college in the
mid 1970s the term welfare queen was
being popularized by Ronald Reagan as he
campaigned for president and was
starting to be taken up by the mass
media it would soon go on to upstage the
Outland commie and well-worn dirty
hippie as objects of vitriol in the
American political imagination
self-described regular decent Americans
had in welfare queen a new image against
which to define themselves there had
long been accounts of people scamming
the government in one way or another
contractors overcharging politicians on
the take crooked cops but the trope of
the welfare queen was let nicely
constructed to seep into a white
American psyche already anxious in the
1970s and 1980s about race single
mothers and in urban culture that
challenged more than a few mainstream
myths says Michael Roth the president of
Wesleyan University today I'm a college
president and a teacher at the school
known for student activism and I've
noticed a new trope on the scene with
rising potential as a national scapegoat
it is the politically correct woke
college students if the sin of the
welfare queen were crazy laugh ting a
crafty laziness and promiscuity the sins
of the woke so-called social justice
warrior are elitist condescension and a
failure to connect with the needs of
real people well so far that description
seems fairly on to me like the welfare
queen the woke student activists ik is a
convenient type one who unites others in
opposition to what they imagine is wrong
with the country young woke people have
aroused the choreographed indignation of
leaders as different as presidents
Donald Trump and Barack Obama by the way
there's an entire piece over the weekend
I believe
the New York Times trying to
characterize Barack Obama as a
conservative that's how far left the
Democratic Party has moved literally
called Barack Obama the progenitor of
nationalized health care and the creator
of Obamacare the man behind a massive
stimulus package the man behind heavy
regulations of virtually every area of
American life a man behind a
pusillanimous foreign policy that
undercut America's allies in the world
that guy they call them conservative
that's how far left the Democrats have
moved apparently according to this
president over at Wesleyan University
it's very bad we shouldn't talk about
the evils of woke college students he
says denouncing college students be they
long-haired protesters in the 1960s the
environmentalists tree huggers in the
1990s or the pronoun police errs today
is bound to please in a number of
circles like the welfare queens of
you're the stereotype of the woke social
justice warrior only concerned with
canceling other people is a politically
useful if wildly misleading figure know
what nobody wants to fit this
description and in my experience very
few actually do well no you aren't you
are just one of the people who's making
excuses for them you allow the students
to take over the university anytime you
please is it sure there are cases of
student protesters who angrily denounced
practices the previous generations
thought were emblematic of fairness or
free expression student newspapers at
Northwestern and Harvard were criticized
within the last month for listed
soliciting a statement from ice in the
case of the Harvard Crimson and for
tracking down student activists for
their statements on a disruptive protest
in the case of a date of The Daily
Northwestern in both cases some of the
young journalists were taken off guard
and wanted to apologize to their fellow
students on the Left they were quickly
pounced upon by pundits in bouncing
bouncing bouncing while less attention
was paid to those other students at the
newspapers who defended young
journalists reporting practices and
their editorial autonomy it turns out
there was a healthy debate in newsrooms
after all it says conversations about
race the economy by a sexual-assault
climate change or the winner-take-all
economy all tend to involve strong
emotions and challenging complexity
sometimes people complain they don't
want to speak up because they fear being
criticized or stigmatized but they
should recognize their fear isn't
somebody else's fault isn't a sign of
their environments political correctness
or hostility toward free expression
their fear of speaking out is just a
sign they need more courage for requires
courage to stay engaged with difference
or alternatively if you're a
conservative on college campus you very
often will face discrimination from
professors and a minute
traitors you'll face the hatred of your
fellow students and social exclusion of
your fellow students and that's kind of
an ugly thing on college campuses that
are supposed to be promoting free speech
by the way I've been shouted down at a
number of universities I've had friends
in the past couple of weeks you've been
shouted down at universities this notion
that whoa college students are just
there to enrich the debate is nonsense
it's nonsense there's a difference
between the good-hearted liberal who
wants to have a conversation and the
woke social justice left warriors who
wants to ensure that the conversation
has never had he says these scapegoats
are meant to inspire solidarity in a
group by providing an object for its
hostility and educators and civic
leaders should not play along says the
says Michael Roth of Wesleyan instead of
arousing easy antipathy they should
strive to cultivate the robust exchange
of ideas across differences yes I am
sure that Wesleyan will be hosting all
sorts of conservatives to have open
conversations about these issues I look
forward to speaking at Wesleyan with the
with the go-ahead of the administration
by the way this is the same idiot who
wrote a piece in The New York Times in
August called don't dismiss safe spaces
talking about how the university's
primary obligation is to provide a safe
space for students so at the same time
he's pretending that woke students
wanted to mate he's suggesting that a
debate itself undermines their safe
spaces man said the left is moving left
at an extraordinary rate and they're
going to leave the voting public behind
all righty time for a quick thing I like
and then a quick thing that I hate so
things that I like today so Chris Pratt
the actor has a really cool GoFundMe
that he's got going it's called the
tomorrow it's called the win a visit to
visit Chris Pratt on the set of the
tomorrow where you can check it out at
go fund me.com basically he is raising a
bunch of money for the brain treatment
Foundation which is a 501 C 3 non-profit
organization dedicated to providing
support for brain health initiatives
relating to treatment rehab research and
public education this organization is
specifically designed to serve American
combat veterans whose lives have been
severely impacted by traumatic brain
injury plus if you give you have a
chance to win and visit Pratt on the on
the set of the tomorrow war in Atlanta
Georgia
so that's super cool so go check it out
give some charity it's pretty neat
once again it's a GoFundMe and you can
find it under win a trip
to visit Chris Pratt on the set of the
tomorrow war pretty pretty cool cause
already time for a quick thing that I
hate okay so thing that I hate number
one you have to acknowledge that the
same media that are pushing the idea
that drag queens are gonna take down
Trump they may have lost all touch with
reality let me give you an example Joan
Walsh over at salon.com who lost touch
with reality a long time ago she freaked
out yesterday why because President
Trump brought Conan the world's most
famous dog to the White House Conan of
course is the dog that helped chase down
all Baghdady the leader of Isis before
he blew himself up Joan Walsh tweeted
that she was upset by how President
Trump tweeted treated the dog she said
this is terrifying
Trump and Melania exude coldness tikona
and the hero dog they exude coldness
don't you understand Trump should have
been just letting the dog jump all over
him and lick him I mean it should have
been like an outtake from Lassie
Milano whose coat is slightly McCobb to
me but others may find it lovely moves
away from Konya and multiple times oh
you mean that Melania doesn't want to
get dirty from the dog yeah I'm just
confused here it's scary if Melania
isn't like riding the dog around Joan
washes Trump tells you how incredible
this particular type of dog is
repeatedly
when he clearly can't remember the name
of the breed or other details he tells
us he really wanted the dog to be
muzzled which tells you about his fear
okay really that seriously John Walsh so
he can't remember the breed of dog and
this is evil and also he he's fearful of
the dog Conan is a tough cookie we
learned still nothing about his breed
Trump repeatedly jokes about siccing the
dog on journalists also again his
command of the language rivals maybe a
five-year-old terrifying terrifying do
you understand Trump said stuff about a
dog now I'm old enough to remember when
the media were very upset at the idea
that Trump was even going to have the
dog to the White House and then from was
like sure I'll have the dog to the White
House he tweeted out a meme that we made
of him giving a medal to the dog and the
media were like fact-check he hasn't
given a medal to a dog fat jack that's
not true well Trump actually brought the
dog to the White House apparently he did
give him a tuck and Joan Walsh loses her
bleep over it
because everything is incredibly stupid
so well done John
okay time for one more quick thing that
I ate so AOC who when she is not
attending drag queen events at the
Kennedy Center is speaking idiotic ly
about economics
she has an economics degree from Boston
University which really does not say a
lot for Boston University
here is a OC trying to explain what a
public good isn't failing dramatically
[Music]
yeah well she's shaking her head and
that means that she's very serious about
this
okay she's talking here about free
college free college is not a public
good and public good is defined by two
particular factors one is non-rivalry
and one is non excludability non-rival
risk means my use of the public good
does not diminish your use of the public
good I use a water found that doesn't
stop you from using a water fountain non
non-excludable means I can't stop you
from using the water fountain right so
that presumably is public good hey road
a good example of a public good I can't
stop you from using it and also my use
of the roads it's not diminish your use
of the road you know to free college
education has in common with that
nothing nothing
because it serves you and I don't get it
right your education does not have
anything to do with me it is not a
shared good it is exclusive to you it is
your education hey this is just it's in
absurdity but again her understanding of
economics is rivaled only by her
knowledge of foreign policy which is to
say she has none already we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessa
vera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
president Trump gives Conan the
terrorist chomping canine killing
machine a plaque and a medal at the
White House on the same day that he
signs sweeping animal cruelty
legislation and while Conan is the
goodest boy in the country the law is
very bad we will examine our broken
moral compass all that and a lot more
check it out on the Michael Dahl show
[Music]